الاسلحه الغربيه دورا مهما في تحويل ساحه
المعارك باوكرانيا لكن تمت اسلحه احتجت
كييف الى ضغط كبير وطويل حتى حصلت عليه
منها الدبابات الغربيه كالالمانيه من طراز
ليوبارد وابرز الامريكيه وتشالنجر
البريطانيه
المدى تقول لندن انها تزود اوكرانيا
بصواريخ من طراز ستوم شادو مداها يبلغ
اكثر من 250 كيلومترا لكن تمت ما تسعى
اليه اوكرانيا ايضا مقاتله طالما رفضت
واشنطن تسليمها لاوكرانيا باتت كييف اقرب
الى تسلمها لكن من طرف ثالث
المقاتله اف 16 او الصقر المهاجم طائره
مقاتله تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت مثاليه في
تنفيذ الهجمات جوجو وجو ارض لهذه المقاتله
القدره على التحليق على ارتفاعات مختلفه
ويمكنها التحليق لاكثر من 860 كيلومترا
قبل العوده لقعدتها بتسارع 9 جي اي بتسعه
اضعاف قوه الجاذبيه وهو ما يتجاوز قدرات
الطائرات المقاتله قادره على رصد اهدافها
بدقه في جميع الظروف الجويه كما تكشف
الطائرات التي تحلق على ارتفاع منخفض
يمكنها اصابه اهدافها بدقه والدفاع عن
نفسها ضد الطائرات المعاديه قمره القياده
للطيار توفر رؤيه خاليه من اي نقاط عمياء
الطائره مزوده بانظمه متقدمه بتحديد
المواقع الجغرافيه وانظمه ملاحه جويه
ومعلومات توجيهيه للطيار وانظمه اتصالات
راديويه متقدمه هذه المقاتله تريدها كييف
لتعزيز قدراتها على اسقاط الصواريخ التي
تطلقها المقاتله الروسيه كما يمكنها ان
تكون عاملا راضعا لا وكرانيا ضد القوات
الجويه الروسيه
ارسال هذه المقاتله يثير مخاوف مسؤولين
امريكيين فتزويد كييف بها يعني تقليصا
لتمويل احتياجات كييف الدفاعيه الاخرى
لفتره الحاليه اضافه الى اشهر من التدريب
للطيارين الاوكرانيين عليها
16 ستساهم في تغيير موازين القوه
والمعادله العسكريه على الارض كما فعلت
اسلحه غربيه وصلت ميادين المعارك سابقا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات